why does it basically goes calm enough
this is so unbelievably this is like the
present
[Music]
hi I'm Alexis on this season a friend in
town I'm going up and down the west
coast to meet some friends and try the
best food in their cities but first
we've got a star in LA
my friend Amir is coming to visit me for
the day and I've got a great day plan
whenever our mears come to LA we only
get to see each other at the LA office
he's so curious and he loves food and I
really want to show him what makes this
city so special first off I want to take
all mayor to a really popular spot
that's a go-to for any tourist visiting
LA eggslut at Grand Central Market then
we're heading to my favorite local spot
Ricky's fish tacos before ending the day
at Providence one of the most exclusive
meals in the city amazing we're going to
egg slippers all right let's go Grand
Central Market is such an incredible
place for tourists to go because it
really gives them a sense of the LA food
scene it's right in the heart of
downtown LA it's got so many options
it's really a melting pot of all the
cuisines that make LA so special it
almost makes me think of a coming from
New York like a hybrid of Essex Street
Market and smorgasbord a little bit
yeah I think the diversity is like what
makes it so special and so interesting
just a Monday and there's a huge life I
know I mean the line itself is
ridiculous but it is ruthless what's
your favorite breakfast and cheddar and
some kind of chipotle mayo something
aioli there's some kind of sauce we're
gonna get two of the Fairfax sandwiches
the egg that's a pretty interesting name
for a restaurant yeah
it really you know it's been around
since 2011 and it's really blown up I
think I don't want to say because of the
name but I think the name definitely has
helped garner some interest so we're
getting the Fairfax which is the classic
sandwich it's one of their most popular
ones it's got this soft scrambled eggs
with chives cheddar cheese the whole
thing is like this pillowy and clouds I
hope you like
[Music]
so this is the Fairfax we've got a soft
scramble it's chives there's cheddar
cheese sriracha mayo
it's basically your dream sandwich I
think I'm in love I mean it looks like
the most beautiful egg sandwich you
could ever imagine
it's honestly like this is worth the
line it's worth the wait it's so so good
this might be like some of the stuff
just scrambled eggs I think I've ever
had with the brioche it feels like it's
on a cloud that cheese this is scraping
over the eggs oh my god is it the best
egg sandwich I've ever had yeah I think
was worth that line I know hard to
imagine but we have so much more food to
eat today yeah that's what I'm here for
let's do it before a next stop I want to
show Ahmir a cute part of la's history
so we're here at Angel's play it's the
shortest railway in the world and it was
built in LA around the turn of the
century and it's kind of this like fun
little thing to do you know as you can
see you don't really go anywhere but
it's a part of LA history that if you're
downtown you should definitely
experience
it's kind of like a silly thing to do
but it's also kind of cute and fun to
see this part of history I'm pretty sure
where Ricky's fish tacos which is my
favorite fish taco truck in all of Los
Angeles probably the world and those
tourists aren't gonna drive to a food
truck under a bridge unlike the east
side of town are you guys doing my name
is Ricardo Pina aka Ricky Ricky's fish
taco started almost nine years ago
basically what we have in the mania is
fish shrimp and lobster tacos the fish
taco is to be better if you lay and top
with cabbage and pico de gallo on a warm
tortilla we make to order every single
taco so we want to keep it simple -
shrimp tacos cabbage happy but I got you
on your taco everything right everything
thank you thanks the view batter started
out back in the 40s in Ensenada the
recipe I used is part of my family it's
our culture shrimp is being devayne and
butterflies are you so I filet which is
a head fish so we just keep the fish in
one by kid the shrimp and in the other
and then deep-fry it so we're gonna make
tortillas now this is the thick side of
the turkey yeah this is the rough side
which is thinner so you always do take
side down first a lot of people say that
the secret to a good taco is a good
salsa I always said also the tortilla
not only the salsa so we're ready to
plate a little bit of cabbage and pico
de gallo thank you
on a fish taco how spicy is this it's
when you come to we kiss fish that goes
you can't expect original recipe
delicious met crispy on the outside
melts in your mouth of the inside my
life and building that's okay it's gonna
be really really messy but we just have
to go in and do it
oh my god the batter so crispy so crispy
and the crunchiness is the slaw it's
just the perfect time it's my favorite
local spot in LA you know it's been
written up in so many publications but
it really does feel like a spot that was
but they are truly
the best and they're so yeah I don't
know how I'd ever know about this place
man
yeah exactly
oh man it's like the best job I've ever
had it sounded flavorful this is finally
the thing about fryer
are you ready for this one that's yeah I
want to go on water
damn this is delicious
[Music]
we're on Azlan bow in Echo Park lay one
of the best parts about this Lake is
there's this incredible views of
downtown LA this is so unbelievably
we're gonna be still ready for
Providence after this I know
11 courses but honestly like I'm ready I
think we should go get maybe a few more
excellent Providence this is what I've
been looking forward to the most of this
entire day you know I've wanted to come
here for years since I moved to LA and
it's supposed to be one of the best
dining experiences in all of LA I'm
pretty excited my name is Michael
Cimarusti I'm the chef and owner here at
Providence restaurant in Los Angeles
California where you know fine-dining
restaurants that serves modern American
seafood in recent years we've had a real
focus of just trying to cook as locally
as we can up on the roof we have a bunch
of different herbs and plants that we
grow up there that we harvest we try to
offer the very very best in terms of
service the quality of food and
execution and everything that goes along
with it we're gonna do a tasting menu
I've heard you talk about the place a
lot so I don't think I can be ready but
I'm ready so today we're kind of doing
like greatest hits from what we have on
the menu right now so we always start
out our guests with a series of emu's
bushes so we have an assertion flower so
we grow up on the roof which are filled
with a monkfish liver mousse we have mr.
Sam leaves which are filled with a
tartare of tuna with mustard and tuna
oil and California capers which are
actually mr. shim pods so these are
muscles and they're just glazed in a
very strong like mussel broth this is a
rillette of smoked salmon we brine them
and then hot smoked them and the cracker
is made from a rye grain so these would
be the first things that you receive
when you sit down at the restaurant
oh boy we're gonna start with this just
in case you have a pet iguana at home
these grow all over Los Angeles juice
Cheers Wow
I can't believe a flower tastes like the
ocean I know that's the best tuna
tartare I've ever had the salmon here is
so overwhelmingly fresh and it feels
bright and light so now we're having the
oysters mussels no we're having the
mussels I know what a mussel is good
that's so far my favorite this is like a
dream come true to be here we have very
different standards for showing a friend
around town we have a part of Pacific
rock crab and delicious sweet corn
mousse and then we have a delicious crab
soup that we also make with the bodies
of the crab that we put in the tart and
the corn itself I know we shouldn't do
this for everything but we should choose
that is absolutely incredible
oh the shell is like the most paper-thin
shell I've ever seen I don't even know
what said compare it's like all about
the crab and it's screaming its luscious
it's like a symphony of like crab
flavors then we're serving you a little
oyster a Shikoku oyster which has
delicious granita made with lime juice
and melon topped with a bunch of
different herbs like lemon balm
Hecate and the flowers of oyster plant
which we grow up on the roof as well
which are the most beautiful little
purple flowers which have the most
incredible and convincing flavor of
oysters oh my god the melody there's a
war like small and briny which I really
like the sweetness of the room oh it
feels like a desert almost it does from
there we're gonna start the menu the
formal part of the menu with preparation
of caviar and uni that's served with a
sort of an almond
espuma and spruce
well I've never had caviar before by the
way fish eggs seems like such a specific
thing they really just taste like these
small soft salty but not too salty
Spears yeah and then it just it's just
so funny because they linger on your
tongue just long enough to feel their
roundness and then they just dissolve
sorry I'm acting like a hawk do you want
more of this well too bad you're not
gonna get anything we have a spot prawn
that we served with our version of the
XO and a stuff spot prawn head once we
fry them to a certain point then we add
about prohm broth and scallop broth it's
very rich very flavorful and we just
drop a little canola on the plate of the
XO sauce to eat along the prawn
are you supposed to pick up the head and
suck it out you're welcome to or just
turn it over and oh it's open okay yeah
that's like the best shrimp you've ever
had like time so ten million we sure
this isn't a baby lobster yeah oh my god
and with the sauce ginger garlic it
feels like it brings the sweetness of
the problem today we're gonna serve you
two different main courses is we have
two guests dining today and that's
reflective of the way the tasting menus
are here at Providence feet my dear
grade a5 Wagyu beef and for you sir
Liberty Farms duck breast it's so tender
do you want a bite of this yeah let's do
a little trimming but an existing it
those are the spicy
it feels really exciting and really new
I feel really inspired by this and then
we'll probably send you something sweet
to finish and then that'll be that
for you my dear oh rhubarb compote
poached meringue a little rhubarb sorbet
and this is a creme fraiche creme
anglaise hopefully blueberries are your
favorite blueberry sorbet
a little elderflower foam and a little
yogurt on there as well for you oh my
god it's just the sweetest blueberry
that ever existed I mean it's like it's
every bit of the menu is a reflection of
the seasons you know we try to only work
with what's in season and that means
that the menu changes all the time and
you know really I mean we hope that the
menu sort of tastes like a menu that
could only be prepared here on the coast
of California I can't believe that that
was insane
like one of the best I've had a couple
tasting menus where there might be the
best one and so so bad I feel like I
finally got to see la I think if
somebody is not from here it's so easy
to get it wrong at these places but how
else would I have seen these things
without you it was so good to see you I
hope you come back soon thanks so much
for showing me around I had so many
awesome experiences to choose from in
Los Angeles and now I get to choose how
to pay for them with pant planet from
American Express I'm here thank you so
much for being my friends in town I'm so
glad you got to see LA for the day I
hope you guys follow along for the rest
of the West Coast
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]